you know when you say what about other
intelligence in the universe why haven't
we met all the aliens and so on well
because actually
their sort of perception of the universe
may be so different from ours it's kind
of incoherently different
and it's not something where our
our narrative about how the universe
works
kind of carries over to those those
those kinds of uh uh places so it's it's
a it's in a sense it's a rather humbling
experience because you're realizing that
that you know all the stuff we built in
physics and so on is all we built it
because that's the way that we parse the
universe so to speak and were we to
parse the universe differently we would
have completely different views of
physics
um
and i mean i think the thing that has
been well this is this week's issue is
um uh thinking about that in terms of
mathematics
insofar as we believe that there is this
kind of object that represents the
mathematics of all possible
mathematicses and that we are merely as
mathematicians so to speak we are merely
observers observing some slice of that
object
what is the what is the analog of the
constraints of consciousness and the
physical world on the on sort of what is
a mathematical consciousness so to speak
that's my that's my that's my personal
homework exercise for the week um that's
interesting so this consciousness that
we have isn't necessarily that
we can't communicate with any other
being because the laws of physics that
they perceive is incoherent
do they perceive coherent laws
yes i think so
i think so i mean but the way you think
about it is this
in this kind of rulial space different
points in rule space correspond to
different description languages for the
universe
so
just like in physical space
we have a view of the universe that's
based on the fact that we're sitting on
the earth you know which is in some
corner of some galaxy that's in some
corner of the universe we have a point
of view on the universe based on where
we are in physical space
so similarly in rulial space we have a
point of view on the universe that's
based on where we are in rural space
now the question that we can ask is just
like we can ask for the
extraterrestrials do they live in alpha
centauri or do they live in you know 25
light years away or whatever where do
they live in physical space relative to
us we can also ask the question whether
they live in rule space relative to us
we've not mapped out rule space
nearly as well as we mapped out physical
space so we don't really have a good
sense of those
those distances and those what that
corresponds to but that's kind of the
way to think about it and i i would love
to know you know how close is the
nearest
civilization in rural space people say
you know let's go check out the stars
you know the nearby stars and you know
look at the ones with exoplanets and
things like that and uh you know but
there's a different question which is
kind of in in rural space what's the
closest you know
what's the closest thing we can
recognize so to speak and i don't know
the answer to this and that's some
but i think to the observer themselves
i think it is almost total logical that
things will seem coherent so for example
to do an exercise
let's consider two intelligences that
aren't us
okay so one
that i'm always fond of mentioning is
you know the weather has a mind of its
own it has you know it's doing these
sophisticated computations
but it doesn't have
this kind of single thread of
consciousness type thing i mean we have
in our brains we have actual you know
structures in our brains that lead us to
have this sort of single thread of
attention that kind of sequentializes
all of our experiences and when you know
when people
sort of lose that
they become unconscious so to speak and
and you know we've got you can still
have plenty of neurons firing in your
brain but not have consciousness you
don't have this integration of of kind
of the single thread of experience
and the weather is sort of a bit like
that it's got lots of not neurons but
it's got lots of fluid processes sort of
firing all over the planet
and but it doesn't seem to have any kind
of sort of single thread of experience
that's going on so that's sort of an
example of and if we say can we
communicate with the weather
well
not any way that we know i mean we we we
have something where it's sort of an
incoherently different experience of the
universe than the one we have now if we
put ourselves in the mindset of the
weather
does it have a coherent view of what's
going on
to itself
probably tautologically yes
maybe a better example that's maybe a
little bit closer at hand which i have
not thought through completely
is sort of distributed ais
so in other words you've got an ai but
it isn't just one ai it's a whole
network of computers and it's like what
is its experience of the of the world
and what physics does it imagine is
going on because for example you've got
all these different ais they've got all
these sensors
and they're seeing things that happen
those sensors might be separated by
distances that are quite large compared
to you know that takes significant time
to for signals to travel between them
you know what is its view of the
universe so to speak it's very different
from ours because we're we're localized
at a particular point in space
um etc so it's kind of a good exercise
to try and think through in fact i was i
was sort of trying to inventory and i i
think it's a great setup for a
a piece of science fiction more
difficult than i can then i can
certainly muster which is imagine all
these different scenarios imagine you
are an organism that spans a galaxy
how does the universe look to you
imagine you're an organism
that
routinely ends up on different sides of
the event horizons of black holes what
does the universe look to you imagine
you're an organism so to speak that
lives on photons that's associated with
photons you know where basically
no time has passed from the last
scattering surface a few hundred
thousand years off the beginning of the
universe and now if you're a photon so
it's kind of like what are these
different views of the universe that you
have if you are uh implemented in
different ways and you know there are
probably uh sort of implementation
levels for the universe that involve
kind of just recognizing different
features of this whole network of atoms
of space and so on completely different
from the ones that we recognize in um
you know in our analysis of of the
structure of of the universe
so i mean that that's um
uh
anyway that that's that's kind of my um
uh
my way of thinking about this
it seems like there are two issues here
about extraterrestrial life or
intelligent life one is whether or not
we can communicate with them and the
other is that we can perceive them so
when we're saying that we don't see
extraterrestrial life the argument
you've given seems to be that we can't
communicate or be extremely unlikely
that we'd be able to communicate with it
if we were to encounter it but
does that mean that we can't perceive it
we can see for example a whirlpool or a
hurricane
whether or not we can communicate with
it is another issue so i mean the first
step is
there's a level where we don't even see
it because it's it's it's features of
the structure of space that we are
simply not paying any attention to
you know there there's some detail it's
like like for example
one of my guesses about you know i like
to think about
you know i like to think about history
of science i like to think about how did
people make mistakes in the past
how were things that became obvious
later not seen before and so a question
about today's science is what is there
in today's science that people will say
i can't believe
that they didn't see this
and i'll give you an example one that i
suspect is one of those so you look at a
gas it's got a bunch of molecules
bouncing around
we say the gas has certain pressure it
has a certain temperature but all those
details about all the gas molecules
bouncing around we just say that's
entropy there's no there's no detail
there that we care about it's just
random
that's probably wrong
there's probably another
you know whole pile of other properties
that we should be thinking about there
but we're just not
paying attention to so to speak and so
that's that's an example of of a place
where sort of the extraterrestrials
could be all around us and we just
wouldn't know it because
they are sort of their civilization so
to speak lives in features of space that
we are simply not paying attention to so
that's one possibility another
possibility is
uh yes
there are
things that we can perceive
but they just don't make any sense to us
it doesn't it doesn't uh you know it's
like um
uh like the weather for example where
it doesn't
uh it it makes
i mean you know it makes no sense we
don't have you know what would you talk
to the weather about
you know what is its experience in order
to you know what do we talk to animals
about well not a lot really because you
know there's a certain emotional
kind of commonality that we have with
animals at some level
but mostly we can't really have a a
philosophical discussion with your
average bear so to speak um
and uh the i think the reason
uh you know that that's something that
it
it isn't you know there's a separate
level of issue of sort of the the um uh
sort of this this um beyond just
perceiving that the thing is out there
it's like why is it doing what it's
doing do we have a story about why it's
doing what it's doing do you know if we
don't have any such understanding and
even across time for for our own species
you know you look at archaeological
remains from a few thousand years ago
it's like what on earth were they
thinking we have no idea you know what
would be our communications it might we
might be you know we put ourselves down
a time machine which i don't think can
exist but anyway imagine it um you know
and when we say
uh to some
okay the the to some um
you know person from 3000 years ago
uh you know what are you doing oh they
give a whole explanation about you know
they're pleasing the gods by doing this
thing that does this that does that
and it's like what the heck are you
talking about you know we have no common
uh framework for thinking about these
kinds of things
um so i think that that's you know the
the level at which communication is
possible is is pretty it's pretty narrow